I am so in I'm telling you if you start
a call I'll however much it costs I'm so
in dude I'm so in look at your purse
phone uh my I know why why why is this
dorky okay this is like the new pocket
protector now that my phone has stra I
said look at your purse phone I know
exactly where it is cuz I never lose it
has my credit cards on the other side
okay everyone I know can never find
their phone got mine right here whatever
that's good every now and then you bend
over and it yes it hits you in the face
but that's also fine you got the
Chewbacca phone this is it why is this
dorky it's not I'm normore dude I'm
Normcore till I die Orlando tourist for
life